[Music]
the current state of Public Health is
horrific nearly 50% of adults have some
type of cardiovascular disease 10% of
adults have type 2 diabetes less than 7%
of adults are metabolically healthy wa
and these numbers represent individuals
they have real world consequences and a
lot of us are floating along with no
idea what's happening underneath the
hood we have great intentions we want to
be healthier but we're kind of throwing
darts at a a dartboard with the lights
off my core mission is to empower people
to use science to turn the lights on how
do you help us understand what this 12we
challenge will do for our
[Music]
health I'm extremely proud to introduce
you to our newest brand partner on check
out their lineup of super comfortable
sleek and durable pieces for yourself at
on.com hey everybody happy New Year with
the new year now upon us Comes This
sense of new possibilities of renewed
commitment to self- betterment and I
think it's fair to say that many if not
most of us typically resolve ourselves
in one way or another to improve our
health our fitness or our general well
being around this time of year now I
spend a lot of time thinking about the
nature of change how does one truly
change I'm obsessed with resolving this
question but the answer or I should say
answers are complicated they're complex
and the course of action requires a full
and arduous Reckoning with not just our
bodies and our habits but our minds our
spirit our perspective our past and also
our relationship with a future not yet
told that said there are indeed certain
principles that when practice can and
will move the needle and in thinking
about all of this I want to start the
new year by providing you the audience
with some Compass points as well as a
defined sense of direction to structure
your approach to well-being in the form
of a doable challenge a doable challenge
intended to help create and sustain the
most important habits when it comes to
the health metrics that matter most and
to do this I have invited my sagacious
friend and colleague Simon Hill a
nutrition expert a physiotherapist an
author host of the proof a podcast I
urge you to subscribe to if you haven't
already and simply just one of the
smartest people I know when it comes to
grounded evidence-based advice on diet
nutrition and fitness here today to lay
out the what the how's and the wise of a
comprehensive and very doable program
and
evidence-based habit building challenge
that Simon has created and stress tested
with the intention of providing all of
you and me quite frankly a really solid
structure to frame your nutrition
Fitness longevity and well-being goals
as we Embrace 2024 so Simon welcome back
to the podcast after that
rambling prefatory
monologue um it's interesting because
we're here today uh on the heels of a
podcast that we recorded back in August
of this past year that we ended up not
sharing which brings us here to today so
maybe reflect a little bit upon you know
what happened then what led to uh us
getting back together for this one I'm
still trying to get my head around
sagacious sagacious you are a scious
young lad mate it's a wood I'll have to
look up later it's a hot act to follow
off it's a positive AIT that very well
articulated introduction but thank you
for having me back yeah we had that two
or three hour
conversation and I thoroughly enjoyed it
you know as you know I love going super
deep and I do that each week on my own
podcast I try and
invite domain specific experts you know
people who dedicate 20 or 30 years of
their academic career in some cases
maybe even 40 years to a particular
topic and I sit down and you know
extract as much information as I can
about that topic and my role is to kind
of act as a translator and and help
hopefully make that information more
accessible but inevitably what ends up
happening is I get emails and comments
and you know I listen I read pretty much
every comment on YouTube maybe I
shouldn't yeah maybe in 2024 we can
revise that habit yeah whether it's a
good habit or not I I do take the
feedback from the community very
seriously and I realize my passion is to
go deep and people find those
conversations useful but but of
end up thinking you where do I start how
do I put all of this together and I
think both you and I felt after that
last episode we recorded which maybe one
day it'll be released yeah maybe we can
figure out something that we want to do
with it but the the gist of it is that I
don't know how long we went like over
three hours probably um and I think we
just bit off more than we could chew and
tried to Canvas everything and ended up
down all of these rabbit holes and a lot
of you you know kind of chasing tangents
and a little bit of losing the forest
for the trees and although it was chalk
full of incredible information I think
our shared sense was upon reflecting
upon that conversation was that it might
just serve to confuse people more than
to be helpful yeah and my my core
mission is to empower people make people
feel more confident and sometimes when
you provide too much information as you
say you can distract the attention the
focus from what really matters so upon
reflecting on that episode and you and I
speaking and and speaking with other
colleagues I work very closely with Drew
Harrisburg who you've had on the show
and he's been very influential in this
this this
challenge uh coming together you know
upon that reflection I realized that I
needed to go away and think about a very
simple framework what really matter
matters in terms
of predictors of of Health you know how
healthy we're going to be in 1020 30 40
years and how happy we're going to be
that we can measure so we can be
objective that we can intervene on with
some type of science-based protocol so
that was really the the kind of
framework or Philosophy for this this
Challenge and trying to simplify it
was Finding biomarkers or things that we
can mhm measure that predict longevity
that meet these three criteria number
one is they are great predictors of
longevity number two they are easily or
relatively e easily measured and number
three we can intervene on them with some
type of specificity with evidence-based
protocols and then shift them in a more
favorable Direction and in doing so
improve our health span and Longevity
mhm on top of that these interventions
and these testing protocols have to be
accessible to most people correct they
have to be specific as well and of
course evidence-based with all of the
work that you've done and all the domain
experts that you've spoken to uh I have
no doubt that everything you're going to
share today is sufficiently
evidence-based but in trying to untangle
that knot and truly drill down on what
is most important and other words what
are the levers that when pushed are
going to move the needle the most given
the construct of the typical
individual's busy life where their time
constrained their budget constrained and
they really need to be efficient
economical and focused on those most
important things at the cost of all the
other information out there we're not
suffering from a lack of information on
any of this stuff I think what we need
and and what we're thirsty for is a very
specific
focused set of protocols or a structure
or a framework in which in which all
that information can be condensed and
drilled down to its Essence and
delivered in the package of a set of
principles and interventions that the
everyday person can wrap their head
around practice and in turn move their
own needle towards their health goals
and health B goals yeah and another way
of saying that is this is not a a case
of needing to know more it's just being
able to do what we already know mhm and
what gets
measured gets managed you've probably
heard that before but what gets measured
I think we can take that a step further
and say allows us to optimize what gets
measured can be optimized if you look at
current state of health in this country
country I mean that's why we're doing
this the the current state of Public
Health is is horrific you look at the
statistics from this year nearly 50% of
adults have some type of cardiovascular
disease a third of adults have metabolic
syndrome with metabolic syndrome just
very briefly is a cluster of five
characteristics if you make three of
them then you're considered to have
metab IC syndrome 10% of adults have
type 2 diabetes 40% of adults have
pre-diabetes
30% of adults have non-alcoholic fatty
liver
disease over the age of 65 one in 10
adults have dementia another 22% have
mild cognitive impairment if you were to
go and and look at what percentage of
adults in America would be what we would
deem metabolically healthy that
statistic even more shocking
it's less than 7% of adults wow so these
are the numbers that we're up against
and these numbers they represent
individuals they represent individuals
who I get emails from that are suffering
their quality of life is being
negatively affected so this is why we're
doing the challenge and you know why I
spend so much time thinking about
creating a a plan that is evidence-based
interactional and will really shift the
needle and give people um confidence the
predictors of of longevity that I
focused on here we're really speaking to
four Key Systems of the body they are
the cardiovascular system metabolic
system muscular sceletal system and
psychological well-being or emotional
health so we had a long laundry list of
things that you can measure to act as a
window into how those systems are
operating and again I mentioned at the
outset we had spe specific criteria what
are the best predictors in each of these
different systems of the body that we
can measure and that we can intervene on
mhm and we were able to reduce that very
long laundry list down to what we've
called the 10
truths and so this is a list of 10
things that we can meure
measure and in doing that we can really
get a an understanding of our current
health status and what we just what
we've called a longevity score and from
there we can intervene with some degree
of specificity based on the evidence
that we
have what protocols can shift specific
biomarkers in the right direction and
then we can we can retest afterwards and
so that's really the the premise of the
challenge is we're going to test the 10
truths at the beginning to get a window
into these four Key Systems of the body
we'll do the challenge Al together from
February 1 and then afterwards we retest
everything and we can see how that
longevity score has shifted so we're
going to drill down on the 10 truths and
the specifics of the challenge but just
to kind of set the stage
and contextualize this this is a
challenge that we're we're we're
releasing this podcast on January 1st
the challenge will actually begin on
February 1st so everybody has a month to
get their blood worked done and we're
going to get into the specifics of that
that's the testing piece so you have a
baseline of where you're at and a window
into not only your 10 truths but a can
sort of 10,000 ft look at those four Key
Systems in the body then there will be a
12 week period of challenges um and then
at the at the end of that you will test
again and measure the results so that's
the basic premise here right test inter
vain retest principle that we want to
really drive home um I should add
there's a couple of caveats there where
that people should be aware of
let's say for example you can't do the
testing then you can still participate
in the challenge even though that's not
our recommended approach I would rather
people understand where their Baseline
health is before they intervene and then
see how it shifts I think that in itself
can be very motivating and help some of
these habits stick you know of course
this is a 12we challenge but the idea is
that we're introducing people to very
effective evidence-based lifestyle
habits that hopefully they continue on
with afterwards and then the the other
caveat is that we're starting February
1st and that's when the community will
be doing this together it's when I'll be
jumping on Instagram live and on my
stories and you know each week There's a
different theme that we'll be dedicating
that that week too and and providing
education and coaching on but if for
some reason you cannot start on Fe
February 1st you can still do this
Challenge on your own at your own right
so if somebody's listening to this or
watching this a year from now they can
still exactly uh begin the challenge so
let's just walk through the fundamentals
and the basics of it essentially what
you're going to do is the first thing
you're going to do is you're going to go
to your website right the proof.com
livingproof and what happens when you go
to that page so that's the landing page
for the living proof challenge which is
what we've called it and here it'll take
you through the different steps so step
one is understanding where your Baseline
health status is at which means
measuring each of the 10 truths and
there will be guidance on how to do that
so for example four of those 10 truths
are blood tests so you you can get a
blood test we've partnered with inside
tracker and have a discount that people
can make use of if they want to use
inside
tracker then there's functional tests
like grip strength and a shuttle test or
beep test- which is a great way of
approximating your V2
Max and so on and so on and so we guide
you through how to measure each of the
truths once you've measured them you can
put them into our calculator there's a
link to the calculator on that that
landing page which then gives you your
longevity
score now you're ready to start the
challenge again on that landing page
you'll be able to download the PDF which
will have the complete 12 we
challenge within that document there's
also a recommended supplement protocol
there's references to support all of the
interventions that we're recommending
across the the um 12 weeks and you'll be
getting emails along the way as I said
which will be with coaching uh and
providing key learnings that speak to
specific topics so I've been able to go
back through a lot of you know 2 3our
podcasts even seven hours I did with
with Thomas dpring on on lipids and just
pull out some of the you know five
10minute nuggets of information so that
we can provide that as a very quick key
learning which will help emphasize why
we're doing some of the things that
we're doing and at the end of the 12
weeks
uh you'll go back to that landing page
you having retested everything put all
your information back into the
calculator and you can see how that
longevity score has
changed so we should point out this is
no cost this is free for anybody who
wants to do it you have to pay for your
own blood work and that kind of thing
right but there's no fee to to join this
challenge you just go to your website
you can download the PDF you enter your
email you'll get we emails that will
help guide you through it and your hand
kind of gets held throughout this whole
process yeah the idea was to make
this the challenge at least zero cost
and make the whole thing as accessible
and as affordable as possible and you
know our various Partners have helped
make that possible which is amazing um
but as you say you know it can be as
little as Z to do this if you were not
going to go ahead and do the
testing so it begins with series of
tests some of them are strength tests
Fitness tests some of them are blood
work tests like Simon said we've
partnered with inside tracker they're
providing a discount on the blood work
piece and you'll be able to find the
code and the link to all of that on
Simon's website when you go to that
landing page um and from there the
weekly challenges each week is a
different theme drilling down on a
specific aspect of this I want to get to
the longevity score and all of that but
I think should walk through these 10
truths and how they relate to the four
Key Systems in the body that you've
already identified cardiovascular
metabolic muscular skeletal and
psychological emotional well-being MH so
what are these 10 truths and how did you
arrive upon these as the most important
variables or levers to look at in terms
of moving the needle on one's Health
Okay so maybe we should go through
system by system so if we start with
cardiovascular SL cardiorespiratory
health there's three biomarkers that we
want to test here they are
apob blood pressure and V2
Max so let's start with
APO the most common type of
cardiovascular disease is
atherosclerotic cardiovascular disease
people probably have heard of that term
here and there in in in very simple
terms what that means is it's the type
of cardiovascular disease where plaque
is building up in an artery and it can
lead to obstruction of blood to the
heart you can have a heart attack or
obstruction of blood flow to the brain
and you can have a stroke and this is
the number one killer this is of all
things to be focused on and concerned
about this is Paramount this is
absolutely
Paramount and you know over the last 50
or 70 years the science Community has
been able to
identify what is the primary cause of
this there are particular um
lipoproteins in our blood which is just
a fancy way of saying A protein that
carries fats you know because fats are
not water soluble so they can't freely
flow through the blood like glucose can
they need to be carried by something so
that we package these fats and
cholesterol up onto a protein and that
allows them to move through circulation
primarily so we can take those fats to
tissues and they can use them to produce
energy some of these lipoproteins are
considered
atherogenic that means that they can
penetrate the artery wall and become
stuck and the contents the cholesterol
and the fat this builds up and you get
the the building up of the CLK as I
mentioned which can become a problem
over decades it's not something that
results in a heart attack in a matter of
years it's about lifetime exposure very
similar to smoking cigarettes now LDL
cholesterol has been the biomarker for a
long time that's been really measured as
a a kind of surrogate way of looking at
what concentration of these atherogenic
lipoproteins do we have circulating in
our blood but LDL or lowdensity
lipoprotein is not is not the only
atherogenic lipoprotein there's a family
of them so there's LDL there's IDL and
vldl in short when you measure APO
because each one of those lipoproteins
has one APO you get the summation the
total of all arenic lipoproteins in the
blood oh that's interesting so APO is
basically the common denominator amongst
all lipoproteins allogenic lipoproteins
so HDL for example does not have an APO
it has a different protein attached to
it the beautiful thing about apob is
that all of the lipoproteins that we
know that can penetrate and build up
into the artery wall have one apob so if
we measure apob we can get a very clear
understanding as to the total burden of
these atherogenic lipoprotein in
circulation so this makes testing for
apop the number one indicator of
cardiovascular health or lack thereof
what's interesting is that this is still
relatively new uh it's interesting that
that why did it take so long to figure
this out LDL has always been kind of the
gold standard marker in terms of
cardiovascular health and to this day a
lot of general practitioner doctors if
you ask them to do an apop test that's
there's some confusion right it's still
not as M there's not an there still
isn't an adquate enough mainstream
awareness around this marker as being as
important as it actually is is that
correct I asked Dr Thomas D bring this
question and if you look at the
peer-reviewed literature it's clear that
apob is a better predictor of
atherosclerotic cardiovascular disease
particularly in 20 or 30% of of the
cases when people
measure his response was that you know
LDL cholesterol is what's been measured
for a long time now it's very hard to
imagine the amount of Education that's
required to get all of the doctors to
understand that LDL
cholesterol just send an email out to
every single doctor and alert and then
get all of the labs to update the
testing that they offer and so the
system takes a little bit longer to
change but you know most of the
prominent voices in lipidology and
preventative
Cardiology are of the opinion that it
will shift to APO B it's just a matter
of time and um for the time being it can
be something that you can request from
your physician but as you say you might
be met with some
resistance um and then companies like
inside tracker have made it easier
theyve I think they added it added it in
the last six months or so yeah and and
that gets to my own blood work the last
time that I had it done which was
February of 2022 was just before they
offered that so I regrettably have never
had my apop tested so in the context of
this challenge I just want to point out
like I'm going to be doing this I need
to do this I've had a relatively
sedentary year compared to Prior years
because of my lower back dilemma but I'm
on a good path with that now and I'm
back to a regimented fitness routine and
I'm really looking to um get structured
and very intentional about what I'm
doing in 2024 so I'm excited about this
too and I'm going to be getting all my
blood work done as well and not to go
too far on a tangent here I know I
promised you yeah we had a whole con we
had a conf before the podcast no
tangents an
intervention that was the intervention
that I need the the intervention that
you need the most is to stay on track my
friend but go ahead I will indulge you
this one time I'm not I promise I'm not
trying to you know show off or or show
how smart I am or anything in fact
everything that I'm presenting and and
in the challenge is is information
mostly from my guests and I'm I'm just
um synthesizing that information but it
be irresponsible for me not to mention
this so within our our
calculator one of the things that we
consider is someone's Baseline level of
cardiovascular disease
risk why is that important well we're
attributing you know zero points to
someone's a b if it's what we call
suboptimal we're attributing half a
point if it's normal and we attribute
one point if it is optimal
but what's optimal for apop depends on
your risk of cardiovascular disease so
we ask that question and within that
question we ask people do you have a
history of smoking do you have
hypertension do you have a history of of
some type of cardiovascular event but
one of the important things that we ask
for is do you have an LP little a level
over 30 Mig per deciliter
and I'm I'm not sure that this is
something a lot of people are aware of
it's something that's been spoken you
know really only over the last couple of
years and there's been some quite
damning research that's come out to show
that this LP little a which is pretty
much 100% driven by genetics so it's not
something that's that's driven by
lifestyle it's not something we can
intervene on with lifestyle which is why
it's not one of the 10 truths
every one of the tentes we can improve
with
lifestyle but this LP little a is a
subclass of LDL primarily driven by
genetics that is particularly
atherogenic about one in six people have
a an Al or a sort of gene
mutation that places them at one one and
a half times the risk of having a
cardiovascular event in their
lifetime every everyone should go out
and measure LP little a as a once off
test there's nothing that you can really
do to modulate LP little a right now as
I said lifestyle doesn't seem to change
it there are uh pharmaceutical companies
looking at drugs that maybe in the
future could lower it if you had
elevated levels but what it tells you if
that's
elevated then you want to be more
aggressive at getting APO down your goal
for apob is actually lower H interesting
so this speaks to the person who has a
genetic non-li style
predisposition to a higher risk of a
cardiovascular event in their life a
genetic predisposition meaning that
there is no
intervention or non-pharmaceutical
intervention that is going to ameliorate
that not yet and that in turn drives the
importance we place upon what your apob
is if your apob is suboptimal and you
have that LP little l alal or genetic
predisposition then that makes uh your
risk even more heightened contrarily or
conversely if somebody doesn't have that
genetic predisposition and their apob is
slightly suboptimal this is of lower
concern than if you're that person who
has tested positive for LP little L is
that a correct rehash of what you just
shared yeah I think that's that's
correct and and the way that I would
look at this is
that if you're considered high risk of
cardiovascular disease then your optimal
an optimal apob is under 50 milligrams
per decil so that's if you have a
history of cardiovascular disease you
have hypertension you have smoking or
you have type 2 diabetes any of those or
you have this LPA gene mutation which
causes LP little a to be really
high
then your target for APO B is lower you
want it to be under 50 milligrams per
deciliter so if you're highrisk of
cardiovascular disease the target for
apob is under 50 milligrams per
deciliter if you're considered low risk
then the target is under 80 mg per decil
essentially what what we're saying is if
you have all these other risk factors
that are going against you then you
don't want to just stack a PO B on top
of them you want to be more aggressive
at getting that down interesting and
your calculator in the context of this
challenge takes that into consideration
through questions that you ask the
person when they sign up so that gets
factored into the longevity score that
gets associated with this one truth
which is how meaningful is your apop
results exactly and the calculator is
considering you know for many of these
10 truths is considering questions like
that it's also considering your sex and
your age these other factors that for
some of these 10 truths you know what is
suboptimal what is normal and what is
optimal is different depending on your
age and your gender so we've considered
you know all of that when we've been
kind of putting it
together
every athlete I know is going to tell
you that having the right gear is key to
Performance if what you're wearing is
poorly crafted it's just going to put
distance between you and those goals
you've set you owe it to yourself to
invest in the best and the best is on
I'm obsessed with the cloud Ultra great
on the trails and I just got the new
NextGen Cloud Stratus 3 for the road I'm
loving those but an also has this
incredible line of lightweight high
performance apparel that it's just
beyond anything I've previously dawned
it's like this second to none Second
Skin I love to rock the sweat wicking
Ultra te and the ultra shorts which have
this pocket right at the base of the
spine that perfectly anchors your phone
no jiggle I'm just so proud to partner
with an and I love their vision for the
future where their gear is engineered
for
circularity so check out their amazing
lineup of super comfortable sleek and
durable pieces for yourself at
on.com let's move on to truth number two
blood pressure which actually is the
number one risk factor for
cardiovascular disease believe it or not
and you know more than I think 50% of
adults in this country have
hypertension stage one or stage two
which is a a blood pressure of uh a
systolic blood pressure over
130 so ideal blood pressure was sitting
at
120 over
80 and you know what those numbers just
very briefly mean is the systolic blood
pressure the top number is measuring the
pressure in your arteries as your heart
is Contracting and then the heart
relaxes so that it can receive blood and
as it's relaxing you're measuring the
the pressure in the arteries that's the
diastolic blood pressure pressure for
every 20 mm of mercury that systolic
blood pressure goes above
120 you double your risk of having a
stroke es schic heart disease or other
types of vascular disease that's a
shocking statement I feel like blood
pressure was something that the
generation above me paid a lot attention
paid a lot of attention to and then for
some
reason we don't pay enough attention to
it now I don't hear a lot of people
talking about when the last time you had
your blood pressure oh it's been a long
time like yeah you go to the pharmacy
and you see the cuff like by there and
there's old people taking it uh but it
never occurs to me to do it I don't
think of it as
being um such a powerful indicator of of
risk or health um so what you just
shared is like wow
that's uh in terms of like the biggest
things that can move the needle that
certainly sounds like something that we
should be priori iing better than maybe
we are and there's a study that came out
recently comparing at home measurements
of blood pressure versus in
office and at home measurements are more
predictive of cardiovascular disease and
there could be a few reasons that
explain that it could be the the white
coat effect sometimes people go into get
their blood pressure measured and it
just reads High simply they're anxious
it could be because that it's not being
carried carried out properly in the
clinic you should be resting for 5
minutes your legs shouldn't be crossed
your uh arm or cuff should be at the
level of your heart all of these things
make a a big difference but I'm of the
view and what I
recommend and it sets you back about $40
is to get an Ron atome blood pressure
cuff I have no affiliation with that
company I just know that they make very
reliable devices that accurately measure
blood pressure and you can get
that for a wrist cuff or the um upper
arm cuff and that these are automatic
machines you know you can get manual
blood pressure equipment but they're a
little harder to use if you're not
experienced with them so and they're
accurate enough like I always wonder
like the sort of over-the-counter type
measurement devices that you can find at
your typical Pharmacy like are these
legitimate like these are accurate
enough in that you can monitor over time
and if you see changes whether that be
significant drops or significant
increases then that's a reason to go in
and and see your physician and get a
manual test done MH um but yeah I
certainly I I recommend you know I think
I agree with you it's one of these
things that you I think the last time I
did it was a year ago I recently bought
one of these These Cuffs and I saw you
know there's companies now working on
watches and you know other ways of
giving you kind of realtime blood
pressure which I think is where the the
future is all right so apob that's going
to be part of the blood work that you
get done either with inside tracker or
however you want to do that blood
pressure you can test on your own at
home more accurate anyway uh what's next
next is V2 Max so V2 Max is really
really a measure of our cardio
respiratory
Fitness how much oxygen can we
utilize you know per milliliter per
minute per kilogram of of body weight
you know we use we use oxygen of course
to produce ATP to produce energy and the
higher our cardiorespiratory Fitness the
higher our V2 Max and when we go out and
look at a a population
of let's say 50 or 60 year olds there's
a couple studies now that have have
looked at this and stratify People based
on their V2 Max their cardiorespiratory
Fitness and you can put people into
buckets you know low below average
average above average um Elite for
example and you can then monitor these
people and and the the two stud I'm
thinking of monitored for between 7 and
10 years and you look at the risk of of
dying during that period compared to
people that have
low cardiorespiratory Fitness a low V2
Max people in the elite category are
five times less likely to die during
that follow-up
period we're not asking everyone to be
elite athletes here what I find
incredibly
promising and empowering is that just
going from low to average will half your
risk of death and cardiovascular disease
and researchers have looked at you know
what it would take to do that to get
from low to average and you know you'd
be shocked it's it's in line with what
the recommendations are to do 150
minutes a week of of moderate
intensity exercise in those studies
tracking people's V2 Max and evaluating
the association with longevity or
disease prevention I have to wonder
about confounding variables because if
somebody has a superior or optimal V2
max they're probably practicing a whole
battery of other healthy
lifestyle um habits within the construct
of their life uh so how do you isolate
V2 Max in relationship to longevity and
disease prevention outside of the
influence of those other habits this is
the same problem that really any
observational study has you know how how
do you get a clear view of the variable
of interest to
see what the effect of that is on the
outcome that you're looking at in this
case mortality or or premature death and
what researchers use is called a multi
variate
analysis so they have a statistical
model which accounts for differences
between those different groups low below
average average there probably is
differences in smoking incidents there's
probably differences in alcohol
consumption
BMI all of these things can get factored
into that model now I will say one of
the things I've pushed back on these
studies previously on is that there
doesn't seem to be any adjustment for
diet
quality you know and as you rightly
pointed out people with a higher V2 max
they're paying attention to what they're
eating they probably eating a healthier
diet so can we say that the five times
lower risk of premature death is is
purely based on the V2 Max probably not
there's some residual confounding in
there and there's some other attributes
of their life that are influencing that
but I I think there's enough signal to
to say that it matters MH
mhm V2 Max was something I had
previously thought in my youth was a
genetic predisposition there are certain
people who are born with a crazy V2 Max
they end up becoming these amazing Elite
athletes but in truth V2 Max is
malleable through lifestyle changes you
can influence and increase your V2 Max
so this is to disabuse anybody who's
like walking around with that myth in
their head right and there's some I
think I understand where that's come
from cuz there's great debate you if you
speak to urance athletes and coaches
that have been in the space for a long
time they'll talk about you know case
studies where people have increased
their V2 Max by 40 or 50% and then you
read the literature and you know quite
often they'll say you can probably
increase V2 Max by about 10% but we have
to appreciate that often in these
studies where you're looking at shifting
V2 Max there's a time limit it might be
a six we intervention or an 8we
intervention and usually it's isolating
specific modalities so it'll be
comparing a high-intensity protocol with
a moderate it's not comparing you know
or looking at
multimodal interventions and then
looking over the the long-term so I
think that's where you you see that
discrepancy between the research and
what people in the insurance Community
perhaps have seen obviously we could do
a three-hour podcast on V2 Max alone and
the interventions that are going to move
the needle in terms of improving it and
drill down and all the various training
protocols and philosophies behind them
that is not this podcast suffice it to
say V2 Max is an important lever in
terms of overall well-being and
Longevity and disease prevention this is
one of the 10 truths we're going to try
to move the needle over this 12-week
period through these interventions but
you got to test how does one test for
their V2 Max that in and of itself is um
has spawned a thousand uh Reddit threads
about how to figure this out so in the
most simplistic terms obviously blood
pressure we know how to test that apop
we're going to get a blood test how is
somebody going to figure out what their
V2 Max is there's a bunch of of
different ways is the direct direct way
where you go into a lab and you're
connected to a machine and you're either
on a treadmill or on a bike that's going
to be the most accurate way to determine
your V2 Max proper lactate test lactate
threshold
test and I did one of those recently
with with dexafit who we've actually
partnered with here as well so within
the PDF people can find some in
information out about them um so you can
go in and you can do it that way but I
wanted to make this challenge as
accessible as possible for everyone and
not everyone's going to go in and and do
a VO2 max treadmill test um or although
if you have access to one of those labs
and you can afford it I would highly
suggest it I mean I was doing this super
regularly when I was training for all of
these races and it's quite revealing in
terms of where you think you are with
your Fitness versus where you actually
are and some of the findings I think
you'll discover are quite
counterintuitive because it is extremely
precise if you can't do that go ahead
sorry I interrupted you I went on my own
tangent there I I'm I'm telling you not
to do it I'm doing it myself so I we're
we're keeping this on we're on the
highway we're on the Super Highway here
Simon we're chugging along we're doing
good keep it going feel how do we do
this how do we do the V2 test at home
man come on you've said a precedent yeah
tangents are
completely acceptable so you can you can
do a beep or Shuttle test this has been
done in studies where they've looked at
uh did you ever do a beep test or a shut
test ATO what is that I know that's part
of this whole thing I have no idea what
that is I I just like run slow really
far uh all this running back and forth
and all the high intensity stuff this is
a new world to me there's a lot of
people listening right now that are
having flashbacks and are thinking oh no
the beep test was the the thing at
school that you tried to get out of so
you're running back and forth in the gym
picking up the Eraser you set up you set
up two cones 20 M apart which is give or
take I think it's 65 ft right and
there's a a beep and you're running to
the beep you have to get between the two
cones before the beep and that beep gets
it's PR progressively quicker and
quicker and quicker and quicker so the
amount of time now that you can rest at
each end is getting shorter and shorter
until you get to a point where you're
sprinting from one to the other and
ultimately if you miss one beep you have
the opportunity to make it back to the
other end and you can stay in the game
but if you miss two beeps you fall short
you're out
and at that
point you will have a rating like level
9 shuttle three and we have a a table so
this is one of the other assets that
people will get with the
challenge that tells you with with a
very the correlation coefficient between
this shuttle test and V2 Max is 092 so
it's pretty strong correlation so it
tells you with a fairly High level of of
confidence what your V2 Max
is and you know from there then you can
put that V2 Max straight into the
calculator and I assume in the materials
for the challenge you have details about
the beep interval and all of that like
is there like an app on your phone like
how do you do this at home like how what
do I oh you're he just handed me a piece
of paper so the protocol is completely
laid out we we mentioned the app there's
there's very apps you can download
they're free I recommend connecting the
app up to some type of speaker so it's
loud enough so that you can hear it and
it's as simple as just following the
beep and at at each stage the app tells
you level one shuttle one level one
shuttle two and so that when you
eventually get to your limit you've been
listening you know what level and
shuttle you're up EX okay I love it so
it's basically a test of failure with
which is the same as what you would do
in a lab on a treadmill or on a
stationary bike right but you can do it
on a basketball core any flat surface
and you don't even need a heart rate
monitor is heart rate part of this it's
just you're at your level where wherever
you reach failure that's going to
dictate where you're at and then that
gets calculated in terms of your age MH
and what else like does your body weight
factor into that or just age and gender
age and gender so you just need a flat
hard or firm
surface your Runners
joggers and the app there's many that
you can find that are free to Pace you
that's all you need I love it simple
when am I going to do this together
you're going to laugh I I I rubed I've
rubed a few people into doing it and and
we recently ran a couple of those
Retreats this is not this will not be
like my specialty let's do it and let's
you you should get a chuckle out of this
let's upload that to Instagram um cool
all right apob B we've talked about
blood pressure we've talked about V2 Max
anything that remains to be shared about
V2 Max before we move along here I think
that's sufficient let's keep moving cool
what's next next are the 10 truths which
speak to metabolic health and there's
four of these so trigly
es waste circumference to height
ratio fasting blood glucose and
hba1c so three of those are things that
you'll get on a blood test and the other
one you'll measure with a a tape
measure all of these give insight into
your metabolic Health what is metabolic
health because it it can be a somewhat
abstruse or I guess ambiguous term it's
a buzzword a lot of people are using it
but I'm not sure it's it's clearly
defined the way that I see it is there's
two key critical components of this and
and both are addressed in the challenge
one is that we are storing energy
particularly fat in the right place and
we can delve into that if you want and
the second is that we are able to effici
efficiently convert chemical energy so
the energy in our food into mechanical
energy which requires healthy
mitochondria these are the two key
aspects of metabolic
health and metabolic Health you can
think about as a spectrum it's not that
you go from healthy to type two diabetes
there's a there's a large spectrum and I
spoke to in go s Milan about this in in
our episode and he he really emphasized
the point you know you don't have
pre-diabetes you you don't have type 2
diabetes but if you're not moving your
body as it's made to be moved you will
have mitochondrial Decay it's happening
underneath the hood so there's a a
spectrum and when we begin to
particularly when we begin to store fat
in the wrong place we start to see
elevations in triglycerides we see
elevations in fasting glucose we see an
increase in um waste cumference to high
ratio okay
so basically what we want to do is get
our bodies in a place where we are
efficiently metabolizing
nutrients our bodies are regulated in
terms of how we're storing fat in the
right place place I guess that means the
difference between visceral fat versus
subcutaneous fat or fat as an energy
source and for fat that is an energy
source that or those Foods or those
nutrients are being properly converted
into energy somebody who is
metabolically disregulated has some
level of dysfunction with one one of
these two systems or perhaps both in
many cases and so you might say well
what
determines whether you're storing fat in
the right place or the wrong
place and to that I would say to prevent
us going into a deep dive listened to
the episode I did with Roy Taylor who is
the domain specific expert on visceral
fat ectopic fat type two
diabetes but in short each of us have
what he describes as a personal fat
threshold
and a personal fat threshold essentially
is speaks to our capability to store fat
subcutaneously there's essentially three
different places we can store fat
subcutaneously which just means under
the skin which is
the the more safe place to store fat
it's more benign it doesn't seem to have
these delerious effects on metabolic
Health that's where we want fat if we're
storing
it then there's visceral fat which is
between organs and there's ectopic fat
inside organs particularly the liver and
in the
pancreas it seems that our personal fat
threshold how much fat we can store in
the subcutaneous atopos tissue
compartment is largely determined by
genes and that's actually why the BMI
chart for um Asians is different to
Caucasians because genetically they're
predisposed to visceral fat at a lower
body
mass so our personal fat thresholds are
all a little bit different and that's
why you you can look at two different
people you can have two people in front
of you who have the same body fat
percentage but one of them has type two
diabetes and the other doesn't where
they're storing their fat
differs and once you exceed your
personal fat threshold what happens is
the the the body has to store that
energy somewhere and it begins to store
initially that fat in the
liver and as a liver is you're
increasing the amount of fat that's in
the liver the liver becomes insulin
resistant and this is this is
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease right
and one of the the really key tasks of
the liver and Insulin at the side of the
liver
is insulin actually acts to slow down
glucose being released from the liver
into the blood so when you become
insulin
resistant at the liver you start to see
elevations in blood
glucose and you'll also see elevations
in in insulin as well because the
pancreas initially which produces
insulin will try and compensate for that
it will say hey let's just Let's Just
Produce more insulin and try and get
this glucose level down and for a while
people might be able to maintain normal
glucose levels but their body will be
producing a lot of insulin to do
that over time if the person remains in
an energy Surplus so um you know Roy
Taylor refers to this as energy
toxicity and they continue to build up
fat in the liver eventually there's so
much fat being poured out of the liver
because it can't be stored there it has
to go somewhere else so it goes into
circulation into vldls which are apob
containing lipoproteins so you get
elevations in
APO and the body H has to make a
decision where where are we going to
send these the fat subcutaneous fat
store the subcutaneous tissue site
is full mhm it starts is full the LI is
full now it starts to go into the
pancreas and as it goes into the
pancreas you start to lose this the
function of the beta cells which produce
insulin and this is when you start to
see a reduction in insulin production
over time as the pancreas is really
fighting an uphill battle and becomes
more and more worn out and you get
elevations of fasting blood glucose
elevations of hba1c which are two of of
those four uh truths that that I
mentioned that speak to metabolic Health
the point being here is that people say
to me well how do I know if I'm under my
personal fat
threshold these markers hba1c fasting
glucose waste circumference to height
ratio and
triglycerides offer you a window into
that so explain that specifically one by
one okay so triglycerides I just
mentioned there that as the as you're
getting
increased fat lipid production within
the liver and it's building up with fat
the body has to do something with that
so it packages those triglycerides up
into these lipoproteins called vldl and
pushes them into circulation that's why
you get the elevation so when you get
blood test you are getting a calculation
of the the the volume of those
um vldls is that what you said in your
blood and that that's the triglyceride
metric they're a triglyceride Rich
lipoprotein okay right um waste
circumference to to height ratio we know
that waste circumference is a much
better measure than BMI if we're
thinking about fat distribution and we
want to understand where someone's
holding that fat so when you're your
personal fat
threshold or what I or I should say when
your waist circumference is
increased it is a sign that you have
visceral
fat and that you're storing fat around
the abdomen which is not where we want
it fasting glucose as I as I mentioned
so you know when you become insulin
resistant in the liver and when the the
pancreas begins to get worn out your
glucose levels r ringg your body's
having great difficulty shutting off
glucose production at the liver and hb1c
which is just another measure of blood
glucose but it's looking at an average
over a 3mon window mhm so all of those
together paint this picture so when
somebody gets results for these four
metrics they then do what like this gets
plugged into the calculator and you get
a score from that is there one of these
that's more important than the other are
they all informed in the context of each
other like how do you make sense of
these if you let's say two of them are
elevated the other ones aren't I guess
though if you're truly metabolically
disregulated they're all going to be out
of range right right yeah they usually
go hand inand and I think it's important
to to measure each of them because there
can be some scenarios where you know you
may have an an elevation in fasting
glucose but not in in
triglycerides um but measuring all four
of these is a comprehensive way of
understanding what your risk is of these
metabolic conditions pre-diabetes type 2
diabetes non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease Etc
and if you have exceeded your personal
fat
threshold it seems seems that you know
if someone has is considered overweight
or obese typically they need to lose
about 10 to 15 kilog of body mass in
order to see these things
normalize but it is possible Rich to
have to develop type 2 diabetes and be
of normal BMI one in six people that
have type 2 diabetes have a normal BMI
and Roy Taylor Just published a a a
paper looking at this uh specific
population and he was able to show that
um again if these people lost weight
they didn't need to lose as much weight
so they didn't need to lose 10 or 15 kg
they were a lower body weight to begin
with on average if they lost around 7 or
kg these markers would normalize which
was indicative and they did scanning of
of showing that you're getting fat out
of the pancreas and and the liver and I
guess that's a more direct way of
answering your question these four
biomarkers are essent essentially
telling us if you're storing fat in the
wrong place MH and so we want to
normalize them and then we know that you
do not have excessive fat ectopic fat
fat Within These organs what is the
understanding or the current science in
terms of of metabolic health and
mortality so if somebody is
significantly metabolically
disregulated how does that correlate in
terms of
mortality do we know do we know the
answer to that or yeah we do we I mean
we have data looking at metabolic
syndrome or type 2 diabetes for example
if you have type 2 diabetes you have
double the risk of cardiovascular
disease mortality you know the number
one cause of death so we know that that
poor metabolic health is driving most of
the chronic disease Health burden that
we're seeing today it's driving a lot of
cardiovascular disease it's driving type
2 diabetes non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease and probably a significant chunk
of dementia as
well so the next category would be
the um the truths that fall under
muscular skeletal Health yes right so
there's two things we're asking people
to measure here and that is grip
strength and Bone mineral
density we know that as we age there are
age related changes
to uh sceletal muscle and also to our
bone and this is this is is important
for a few reasons one is that um
strength of our muscles and our ability
to produce force and also the strength
of our bones affects our risk of Falls
and fractures fractures are not a
leading cause of of death but if you
have one there's a very high mortality
rate I think it's 25% if you fracture
your hip there's a 25% mortality rate in
the first year and 8 80% within the 3 to
4 years after that hip fracture if
you're aged 65 or older because of the
domino effect that occurs as a result of
that fracture right and if we want to
prevent Falls then or fractures I should
say then that really boils down to two
things we want to prevent someone from
falling in the first place and if they
do fall we want them to have strong
bones so they don't fracture
so we can get a very good understanding
as to what someone's sort of global
total body strength looks like with a
grip strength test this seems to be
quite indicative of overall body
strength it's not that grip strength
itself is magical and is the kind of
longevity hack we're not going to ask
people to go away and do wrist curls um
necessarily but grip strength is highly
predictive of mortality it's highly
predictive of cardiovascular disease we
know that for every 5 kilogram reduction
in grip strength you have a 16%
increased risk of premature death W
and that's that strength and we can go
as deep as you want but that is that is
dictated by uh a number a number of of
factors it's not just muscle mass you
know there is strength Str independent
of muscle mass as well and a lot of that
is to do with the chemical and the
neural signals that go from the brain to
to the muscle and the the kind of motor
units is what they called which is the
the nerves innovating into the the
muscle tissue we see from the age of
about 40 you start to
lose two
3% of uh
strength on a yearly
basis which is that's a considerable
amount of strength to be losing yeah and
it accelerates the older you get it
accelerates the older we get but we have
to remember that this is looking at
populations that are mostly
sedentary so we shouldn't assume that
that is just the way it is and these are
the age related changes that are going
to occur to our muscle because we know
with certain interventions for example
that you can actually increase the
number of those motor units you can
increase the size of the muscle so there
are things that you can do to at least
attenuate that loss in strength as you
age a couple uh thoughts you mentioned
the difference between muscle mass and
actual strength in other words it's not
just about putting bulk on your body
it's about your body's ability to
recruit the muscle fibers that you have
and to do that efficiently those are two
different things and that recruitment
can be trained of course as can bulk and
grip strength correct me if I'm wrong
this came up in the podcast that I did
with Peter AA it's not that you're going
to train grip strength it's that grip
strength is a proxy or a way of um
getting a sense of what somebody's
overall strength is because if you have
strong grip strength you're probably
doing lots of things or whatever that
are just making you strong and robust
right a byproduct of the way that you're
living yeah so how do we test for grip
strength we use a dynamometer which is a
20 or $30 you just hang from a bar and
like you know count to however long it
takes until you have to let go yeah that
that is a test that's been done but but
probably measures grip endurance more
than strength so the Dynamo allows you
to look at Absolute strength and it's
what's used in these studies where
they're looking at grip strength as a
predictor of mortality they're using a
dynamometer to measure someone's grip
strength and where do you get one how do
you use it how expensive is this thing
20 or $30 I mean like a lot of things in
life you can go out and you can you can
indulge and spend $300 I don't think you
need to do that in in the challenge we
have a link to one that has been used in
studies is about $30 that you can order
on
Amazon and you know the protocol to
measure your grip strength is very
simple we outline those four or five
steps you do your left left side and
your right side and you repeat it three
times and you take an average and then
you plug that into the the calculator
mhm and what gets factored in there
again is Ag and sex and you get a score
for that exactly okay
um grip strength uh what was the other
one bone mineral density so bone mineral
density is measured with a dexa scan we
know that for for every one standard
deviation below the average bone mineral
density of a
30-year-old so every one standard
deviation below which is like a 10%
reduction in bone mineral
density you have a doubling of your risk
of
fracture the dexa scan measures your
what's called a t-core so you get this
number that is exactly that it's
measuring you against the average bone
mineral density of a healthy 30-year-old
adult and so if your score is zero that
is is the average for a 30-year-old
adult if you're minus1 or you're 10%
lower and at from minus1 to - 2.5 is
called
osteopenia so this is the stage before
someone is diagnosed with
osteoporosis which is from minus 2.5 and
down on the Retreats that we just ran
because we had everyone
measure these 10 truths before they came
and it was you and Drew Harrisburg who
were hosting this retreat in Bali and
you put all of your campers like through
a version of this challenge yeah yeah we
I mean we deep dived this entire
challenge we had 90 minute lectures on
cardiovascular system and then on
metabolic health and then on
psychological well-being all the things
and all and all the the 10 truths and
what we're measuring and then all of the
interventions but what what was really
surprising to three of the the guests
who were all postmenopausal women now
postmenopausal women are the the highest
risk category for osteopenia and
osteoporosis and three of these women
who had never done a Dexter
scan for the first time were told that
they had
osteoporosis and that's important
information to know because it can
affect the choices you make with your
lifestyle where are you going to focus
your attention on from an exercise point
of view for example what parts of your
diet do you want to focus on a little
bit more is there pharmacotherapy that's
important um so you know measuring these
things they have real world consequences
I guess is the point that I'm trying to
make here and a lot of us are floating
along through life with really no idea
what's happening underneath the hood
yeah yeah I I'm one of those people I
think um I've always thought bone
mineral density or things like
osteoporosis these are issues that
predominantly concern women more than
men perhaps I'm incorrect in that
assumption I don't know why I
even think that or where that came from
and secondarily that this is something
that would be very unusual to be
concerned about until maybe you're in
your mid-50s in terms of testing and
evaluating so that's a two-part question
so part part one you're right it
is more common to see osis in women
particularly postmenopausal women there
are some other conditions some Prem
menopausal conditions where you can see
osteoporosis um particularly in in
athletes who are restricting energy now
why is that the case the the simple
answer is it's probably driven by
hormones so in that postmenopausal phase
and I did a a two or three hour episode
with Dr Suzanne Davis on on menopause
where we spoke at length about this but
in that postmenopausal phase estrogen
kind of goes off a cliff yeah I just had
Lisa Moscone in here we did a couple
hours on that and one of the key roles
of estrogen is when we load our bone so
you know the the two best ways to load
bone to stimulate it to grow stronger is
you know weightbearing exercise where
there's some type of ground reaction
force that is greater than what we we
would be subjected to just in everyday
life so let's say we walk around all
every day um just walking more is not
going to increase our bone mineral
density but skipping or hopping or
jogging these types of things where you
increase that ground reaction force can
stimulate the body to lay down more bone
but hormones are very important for that
process and estrogen in
particular sort of acts as the signal
between the force is recognized by
estrogen it stimulates estrogen which
then stimulates these cells called
osteoblasts to produce more bone mhm and
so if you have less estrogen around then
you're getting less bang for your buck
when it comes to the stimulus of jogging
or skipping resulting in that adaptation
that you're looking for but there still
is some adaptation there still is some
and I mean that's why I mentioned though
uh pharmacotherapy because you know
depending on someone's context for
example estrogen therapy it's not
indicated for everyone it's
contraindicated for for some people um
but but for others it can be indicated
and can be very helpful for things like
osteoporosis interesting and for men is
there a point at which there's no return
or is this something where interventions
can always lead to improvements I'm just
imagining somebody who gets their bone
mineral density evaluated realizes
they're they're way off the mark um
obviously you you then you have to worry
about fractures right so when you're
talking about loadbearing exercises that
suddenly becomes a precarious uh you
know kind of prospect right you have to
be safe about this but also engageing it
so that you can get that stimulus and
and try to regenerate some of that
density and I think this is why you're
starting to
see these bone health clinics being set
up I'm not sure if you've seen any of I
haven't seen that that's a thing yeah
it's a thing and and you can go in and
do very specific training to increase
your bone mineral density under the
supervision because as you say there
there will be a large percentage of the
population with low bone mineral density
that also quite frankly don't have very
good
balance and and and getting them to do
some of these exercises could be
dangerous so I think if you if you do a
dexer and you have osteoporosis or
osteopenia then that's a time with a
physician and hopefully with an exercise
physiologist if you can access one you
create a really robust plan for you you
know jogging and skipping is not going
to be for everyone it's going to depend
on on someone's Baseline health and
their risk of having a a fracture so I
want people to kind of do this safely
but yes the body can adapt there's some
beautiful studies looking at 80 and 90
year old subjects and even at 80 or 90
you can build muscle and you can
increase bone mineral density okay so
it's not as though it gets too late to
for the body to to adapt to a stimulus
it's it still will but you need to to do
that safely is the only way to get an
accurate sense of your bone mineral
density uh to is to undergo a dexas scan
is there any other way of testing this
I'm just imagining not everybody's going
to have access to this kind of
Technology how does that work
if somebody does want to get a dexa scan
how do they even go about figuring that
out there's some other technology but
that doesn't really speak to the
accessibility uh part of your question
so like there's another um scanning
device called the echo which is becoming
popular but the the dexa scan is by far
the marker that is used in clinical
research to look at risk of fracture
right so we know it's a robust if you
measure your t score we know that that
is a robust marker that can be used
along with other risk factors so there's
we're going a little bit into the weeds
here but if you were in a clinical
setting and you had a Dexter scan and
you were speaking with your physician
and you were trying to work out what's
your 10year risk of a fracture they have
a calculator and they can consider you
know your history of smoking and alcohol
and whether you have osteoporosis in
your family and and all those sorts of
things get factored in uh as well but
certainly this is probably the least
accessible of the 10 truths to measure
I'm aware of that but I think it's
something that everyone should do but
particularly postmenopausal women and I
say everyone because you made a point
before about um you know what happens if
you measure your bone mineral density at
50 60 and it's low is there still enough
time to to change that I think we need
to think about our bones like a savings
account in a
bank and so if we can build that saving
up early in life then we're less likely
to run into issues later in life so I'm
speaking to the young person here now
who's 20 or 30 or in their 40s I don't
I'm not even going to think about this
for another 30 years yeah and I'm saying
you should approach this as your savings
account so um the interventions that are
in the challenge that have been included
in there to promote bone mineral density
should be things that you should try and
integrate into your ra Rim in advance on
top of all of this if you do get a
Dexter scan you're getting a window into
not just your bone mineral density but a
whole number of things your visceral fat
like there's a lot of data that you can
extract from that experience MH yeah so
and and visceral fat I thought about
putting that into this uh these these
truths that we're measuring but I feel
like it's adequately covered with
triglycerides and fasting glucose and
hba1c I spoke to that earlier um I had
my visceral fat measured recently yeah I
you say with a twinkle in your eye yeah
I can brag about it well I feel like I
can brag about it because I I I got so
much on YouTube and on Instagram
for at least a couple of years where um
proponents of an animal-based or
carnival style diet were nagging me to
get a Dexter
scan um saying that you know maybe maybe
I'm I'm fit and strong on the outside
but with that high carbohydrate diet
probably have a lot of visceral fat M
being built up so I was pleasantly
surprised to see that my visceral fat
was almost zero have you made a little
video clapback video about that I
haven't posted anything that is directed
towards that crowd I did put uh some
stories up on my Instagram with the the
results but yeah maybe maybe I should
think about that interesting um if
somebody wants to get a Dexter scan how
do they even go about figuring out where
to go and what does that cost and what
does that entail I went to dexa fit uh
in Boston but they dexa fit are all
around the United States and in in most
countries now there are Studios set up
to measure to do a dexa scan and a V2
Max often are in the same place so dexa
fit do both so if you wanted to to do a
treadmill V2 Max test and a dexa you
know you're wanting to go all out with
measuring your 10 truth prum the Premium
plan yeah then you would go to an
organization like Dex a fit or if you're
in another country something that's
equivalent um we have a partnership with
dexa fit so that if people doing this
challenge who are based in the United
States want to use them they can get
some saving on either the Dexter scan or
V2 Max or both if they choose to do both
but in terms of what it costs um
I probably should know that I think it's
between two or $300 uhuh oh I would have
thought it would have been more I think
it's more if you do both I think that's
the cost just for the dexa scan but
don't quote me on that interesting yeah
but there'll be a link to the dexa fit
situation in the materials uh for the
challenge right so whatever savings or
discount is going to be made available
people can figure that out there exactly
okay um have we covered this this this
uh this system the musculo mus why why
do I have so much tral I have trouble
saying that word musculos skeletal
system I get made fun of for saying
musculoskeletal because in this country
I know you you I've let you I've I've
given you a long rope with some of your
pronunciations uh because I'm trying to
keep it on the rails dude um can we move
on to psychological and emotional
wellbeing any final thoughts
on what we just covered before we go I
think I think we we covered that pretty
comp comprehensively the two truths that
we're measuring to get a window into
your muscular sceletal Health are your
grip strength and your bone mineral
density okay so now we move into this
weird uh you know kind of ephemeral area
like I can understand testing for apop
and grip strength and all this sort of
thing how are you going to create an
accurate way to evaluate somebody's
psychological or emotional wellbeing to
get a baseline before introducing
interventions this was the hardest of
all 10 truths
to find a tool that can accurately
measure that and Encompass all of the
various aspects of emotional health
psychological well-being whether that be
self-esteem or purpose or optimism
relationships you can't just blow into a
tube and have a
number I wish uh so I had to dig pretty
deep here and consulted a number of
different people in Psychology and
psychiatrists and uh came across a toour
called the flourishing scale which was
was produced by a psychologist he went
by the name doctor happiness actually
uh and this is the most robust I guess
clinically validated tool that I could
find it's not the only one that can act
as a relatively simple way to get a
gauge on your psychological well-being
Psychological Resources and strengths
there's eight questions on this
flourishing scale and for each of those
eight questions I have it in front of me
I can read out a couple of a couple of
them so you can kind of get a better
feel for it for each of the eight
questions you either strongly agree
agree slightly agree all the way up to
strongly disagree
MH
and one I I'll read all
it I lead a purposeful and meaningful
life my social relationships are
supportive and rewarding I am engaged
and interested in my daily
activities I actively contribute to the
happiness and well-being of
others so being of service debatable I
am competent and capable in the
activities that are important to
me I am a good person and live a good
life everybody thinks they're a good
person I am optimistic about my
future people respect
me that's a good one and so you know
that's that's the the tool that we've
used to kind of assess this and the
maximum score you can get is uh
56 if you score um eight on sorry seven
on all eight question each one of these
is you score it one to five 1 to seven
and there's eight questions so maximum
score is is uh
56 and you know why these questions why
relationships self-esteem purpose
optimism service well there's a whole
lot of research that underpins that you
know we could we could speak of a number
of of different studies the the one that
maybe people are familiar with is the
Harvard study of adult development which
looked at um a group of students from
Harvard and tracked them for uh 80 years
and they were interested in what were
the greatest predictors of happiness and
Longevity and more than than money or
fame and money was important actually
but up to after a certain level of of
about $75,000 income that might be a
little higher today yeah probably but up
to a certain level after that it wasn't
a great
predictor above all of those and also
above traditional risk factors like LDL
cholesterol and even
smoking the quality of their
relationships were the greatest
predictor of their happiness and their
longevity and Robert waldinger who is
the director of that
study he's very famous for a quote where
he says loneliness
kills
and that is often mistaken for Solitude
being uh
deleterious but I don't actually think
that's the case this some research
looking at how much time you spend by
yourself versus with
others and certainly spending time by
yourself can be healthy and appears to
be healthy but if people are spending
more than 75% of their time by
themselves they're significantly they
they're significantly more likely to
experience loneliness so these are you
know some of the I guess some of the
science that has in formed the decision
to use a scale like this that's you know
measuring some of these questions are
related to relationships there's other
questions in here that are related to
service and there's um some incredible
research looking at the differences
between giving or getting and looking at
the differences in how our brain is
activated yeah and you know you see when
when someone is is giving
something the reward center of the brain
it lights up in in both of those
contexts
but also the stress level of the
brain goes down oh interesting I didn't
know about that piece and so there's
this really interesting uh MRI research
that's shown that which is then
corroborated by population level uh
research where you look at at large
population of people and you use
different questions to determine you
know how frequently someone is service
is of service to others around them and
you see that people who are of service
to others are less likely to die during
the the followup period and on the flip
side you you see that people that are
highly
stressed have much higher risk of of
premature death but the interesting
thing is people that are highly
stressed that are of service do not have
increased risk of mortality oh wow so
that's an interesting Ripple so there's
something about giving and being of
service to others that seems to
attenuate stress and I don't think it's
been fully elucidated exactly what's
happening there but there would be a
physiological explanation and there are
researchers debating as to whether
that's sort of mediated through
inflammation or or other
physiological processes but you know
point being that being of service seems
to be incredibly important when it comes
to our
psychological resilience
well-being and um so that's something
that's evaluated within the flourishing
scale and that's why it was included in
that scale specific speically and then
in our 12we um challenge we have a few
things in there that hopefully inspire
people to be what the interventions are
here or what the exercises are here but
let me just say first of all I I commend
you in tackling a soft science you know
as a hard science guy like you try to
wrap your brain around like how do I
make sense of this very unwieldy world
where um you know data points are less
inter are sort of less Mission critical
than and insights and kind of General
ideas about um where you should place
your your attention and your focus all
of this is of course true and vetted
through the social sciences and the hard
sciences that overlaps or intersects
quite nicely with what we know about the
blue zones and the centenarians as well
as the work that chip Conley is doing
with his modern wisdom modern Elder you
know Academy and um and his his his his
focus on the relationship between
longevity and kind of human Connection
in that regard and then the Surgeon
General who has made loneliness you know
his mission to ameliorate like these are
very real things that we're grappling
with and I think it's cool that you wo
this in as one of the four Key Systems
um because with your background I could
easily to say we just have to focus on
diet and nutrition and you know maybe
brain health what else can we throw in
there strength Etc but this is key and I
think it's important to point out that
you can have an absolutely pristine
perfect diet and you can adhere to your
Fitness routine with extraordinary
consistency but if you're a narcissist
or you're self-obsessed or you're just
an or you isolate from other
human beings and you never consider the
thoughts or emotions of other people uh
not only does that make you just a giant
dude bag it's really not doing a lot for
your longevity right so even if you are
selfish in that regard it is in your
interest to figure out a way to give of
yourself for
others and do you do you want to live a
long life or do you want to live a good
life because for me the difference there
is that living a good life requires
emotional health it requires you to be
happy with with with the things that
you're doing in that time that you're
alive so it was an important
um pillar you know an an important
inclusion within those four
systems emotional wellbe and you can't
deny the science you
know there's there's a reason that the
quality of our relationships are the
number one predictor of
longevity because those
relationships affect our physical body
so yeah I'm glad that we we included it
all right well we're like an hour and 40
minutes into this and now we have our
Baseline right we're good we're on track
for a Five Hour
podcast that's a joke s um okay so on
the template of test intervention retest
we have our test results we have a
baseline for where we're at now we're
into the intervention phase of this and
obviously we can't address add every
single aspect of this so how do you help
us understand what this 12we challenge
will involve before the retest at the
conclusion of those 12 weeks okay so
let's startop very high level there are
12 different lifestyle
habits and these are split across
nutrition exercise sleep and emotional
well-being each week there are focuses
for nutrition for exercise for sleep and
emotional well-being and we start off in
week one relatively gently and then over
the course of the 12 weeks we're
building on what we're putting into
practice and we're making it more and
more challenging such that at week 12 we
arrive at a point where the evidence
suggests you will have significantly
shifted your longevity score those 10
truths mhm so then you can do your
retest and you can see proof that this
program has worked and has shifted your
health in a favorable direction do you
need perfect adherence to achieve this
you do not need perfect adherence in
fact I would encourage people
to not be so hard on themselves I don't
expect 100% adherence we've we've
factored that in to what we're
recommending now we're going to provide
coaching and emails and reminders along
the way to to kind of help encourage and
improve adherence but even if you were
to adhere to this 70 or 80% you're going
to get improvements in your
health
so you know for example some of the the
lifestyle habits that we've
included from nutrition perspective we
we want be able to optimize that protein
intake we think that's important for a
variety of reasons now the the total
amount of protein that you consume has a
direct effect on your strength it
affects bone mineral
density but also where that protein's
coming from affects your cardi metabolic
health risk factors so we're providing
people with a target for total protein
intake but then we're also recommending
that they're getting at least a certain
amount of that from plant protein and we
have a a whole guide on protein so that
they people can see what are the the the
really good sources of plant protein on
a per calorie basis and so if they're
not familiar with that they can um make
some decisions more
easily we have a a a lifestyle habit
built around fats so we're encouraging
um people to cook with olive or avocado
oil instead of butter or Tallow or
coconut or palm oil Does it include
recipes or just general guidelines so we
have we have both the the guidelines are
General in the weekly learnings people
will get some recipes so for example in
week one the theme of that week is built
around protein so each week there is a
different theme that we're educating on
and in that in that week we have a short
video that we want people to to watch
you know I've interviewed Stuart
Phillips Don Layman Chris Gardner Vol
Longo all these guys with slightly
different research backgrounds different
individual or personal diets themselves
who all have really um important things
to say about protein so we've pulled
some of that information together for
people to listen to just finding the
specific pieces that relate to the theme
or the subject matter that you're trying
to address and organizing that in a in a
way that is helpful to the to the person
and then that week they do get recipes
so they get a a high protein plant-based
recipe PDF which has sort of 15 or 20
different recipe ideas in there how much
of a time commitment is this whole thing
a lot of this is set and
forget the exercise component is the
most time
consuming how much time a day per week
well we're we're wanting people to by by
week 12 be doing 150 minutes of Zone 23
training per week so we would call Zone
2 three moderate intensity mhm somewhere
in the ballpark of say 60 to 80% ma Max
High rate so that's 150 minutes a week 2
and 1/2
hours we want people to be
doing working up to a 4x4 minute hit
interval per
week with a warm up and a cool down
that's another 30 minutes so you're at 3
hours of
training from a cardiovascular exercise
point of view across a week and then on
top of that resistance training by week
12 we want people doing at least twice
per
week and those sessions are to be 45 to
60 minutes so let's just say that they
you're doing 60 Minute sessions mhm it's
5 hours of exercise a week that's the
most time consuming part of this program
Which is less than an hour a day if you
if you drag that over 7day week mhm talk
a little bit about the Sleep piece so
sleep we focused on two aspects there
are so many things that we could include
into this challenge yeah well it just
it's a you know it just gets infinitely
more and more complicated right I've had
conversations with domain experts in a
lot of these areas you've had more than
I have uh and if anybody who's listening
to this or watching it wants to drill
down deep on V2 Max or sleep or protein
or whatever just like go to the roof and
get into Simon's archive because I'm
sure that you're going to find what you
want and people are going to talk for
hours about this stuff we're trying to
like canvas it and get get to just the
meat on the bones here yeah exactly so
you can go and find a whole 2our episode
on fermented foods if you
want uh but only two hours yeah yeah
that was one of the shorter ones we're
getting people to focus on sleep
duration so how long are you in bed for
the research is pretty clear that seven
to eight hours of sleep per night is
associated with lower total mortality
premature death now if you're in bed for
8 hours you probably get S hours sleep
I'm not sure if you've ever looked on
your whoop oh yeah it's you know it's
like oh because I used to just think I
went to bed at this time and I woke up
at this time the the whoop uh you know
you realize like oh time in bed is not
necessarily an indicator of how much
time you slept nor is it an indicator
certainly of the restorative phases of
sleep that are most important so we're
recommending that people are in bed for
8 hours per
night
now I think you've had satch and Pander
on no I haven't actually you haven't had
him on okay but you've had episodes on
where you've discussed Cadian rhythms
and Cadian biolog ology and you know
everyone's experienced chronic jet lag
fly across the other side of the world
to Byron Bay where I live and you're
going to feel pretty lousy until you
adjust to that new time
zone what people may be a little less
aware of is that that's a that's a very
sort of acute form of chronic of Cadian
disruption but you can have more of a
chronic Insidious Cadian dis disruption
which is occurring whilst you're staying
in the same time zone because of the way
that you're living and so you know
Cadian biology in short we have these
natural fluctuations of hormones and you
know things like our heart rate and our
blood pressure they change throughout
the day and they really just change in
order to prepare us for what we're about
to do so in the morning things are
changing to get us ready for being
active and get us ready for digesting
food
later in the
evening various physiological processes
are changing based on the Cadian rhythms
to get us ready for rest and
Rejuvenation and renewal
overnight these Cadian
rhythms are primarily affected by two
external
cues in our environment there's two
things that can really throw them out of
whack one one is light exposure so if
we're sitting up late at night in very
very very bright lights it's let's say
it's 900
p.m. our body and it's dark outside our
body we might be sitting in LA but our
body thinks we're in Sydney mhm so we
can cause some disregulation of our
Cadian rhythms and then that affects the
release of melatonin which has an effect
on your sleep for example we can also
dramatically affect these Cadian rhythms
through the timing in which we eat
that's the other really important signal
here so within this challenge we have
two different habits that speak to
nurturing our Cadian rhythms one is
light exposure we want people in the
morning to get outside get at least 10
minutes of natural light exposure in the
first couple of hours of waking up
that's important that sets your clock
mhm this is the huberman protocol around
morning sunlight and then at
nighttime when as the sun's going down
ideally you're you know you're don't
have to turn all the lights off in the
house but it will be helpful if you dim
the lights down and if you're using
screens you can adjust the the
brightness on those and put them into
night mode and then with regards to the
timing of our
food there's some really interesting
research that has come out of Courtney
Peterson's lab I interviewed her looking
at
how efficiently is our body utilizing
nutrients at different times of the
day and it seems that particularly at
nighttime a couple hour a couple of
hours before we go to bed we have
changes in hormones that make things
like glucose glucose
metabolism much less
effective how it makes sense our body is
getting ready to go to sleep not to
digest food and convert it into
energy the ideal kind of eating window
and some people have described this as a
Cadian biology eating window or Cadian
fasting it's not I don't think it's
really a crazy fast is you're in bed for
eight hours a night that's what we said
just before and when you wake up not
eating for one or two hours upon
waking and before you go to bed not
eating for one or two hours before you
go to bed before you go to bed now if
you let's say you you do that as 2 hours
so you you in bed for8 you don't eat for
the first 2 hours of waking up and then
before you go to bed you're not eating
in the 2 hours leading up to bed
automatically that means your eaing
window is at 12 hours mhm the average
person's eating window in America is 15
to 16 hours so pretty much rolling out
of bed having a bite of a
donut and eating all the way up to going
to sleep again the reason why all of
this is important is that we know that
this chronic Cadian disruption
significantly increases risk of
metabolic diseases significantly
increases risk of obesity of
cardiovascular disease so there are
repercussions if we're living in a way
where our Cadian rhythms are disrupted
and it's not just the longterm if you're
experiencing chronic Cadian disruption
you're likely to feel you know more
brain fog more fatigue less lower energy
or
a daily basis so just some roue in place
where we're in bed for 8 hours thinking
about light exposure and then where
eating at a regular time trying to avoid
eating too close to waking up or going
to bed can make a very big difference
this is like my Mount Everest because I
get so hungry at night man it's very
difficult for me to not eat in the two
hours before I go to sleep like that is
my Achilles heel so if I accomplish
nothing other than figuring out how to
master that as a result of doing this
challenge that would be a huge win for
me have you played around with the types
of food that you're eating yeah and and
uh you know when I was wearing a a
continuous glucose monitor is very
evident like when I would eat like right
before going to bed how it would wreak
havoc on me um and and and you know I
wake up I wake up in the middle of the
night and stuff like that and my blood
glucose regulation is is you know super
disregulated as a result of that like I
know I know I shouldn't do it and I it's
just this is a habit that's been very
difficult for me to break I haven't seen
this formally studied so I can't speak
to an intervention but I have a a
hypothesis here and I'm not sure whether
you've tried this but I'd be interested
to see what happens if you have a
slightly low lower carbohydrate dinner
and higher fat
mhm and I suspect because that will be
slower to digest and
metabolize that you might feel Fuller
for longer it's a weird satiety thing
and I don't know if it's just mental or
emotional but if I don't feel full when
I get into bed like I feel like agitated
you know I feel like I need to there's
something emotional or physiological
about you know how you kind of relax
when you have when you when you've just
eaten like your anxiety and your stress
level uh lowers um and for some reason
if I'm going to bed and I'm hungry like
it becomes very difficult for me to fall
asleep I get that you might need a big
biger plate at dinner I I I eat plenty
trust me dude anyway I don't want to get
too sidetracked on that but I think
that's really important and that's great
and if you want to be more uh rigorous
about your sleep tracking there's always
you know like a whoop or something like
that that you can get um that you know
listen I never take this thing off and
it's really been helpful in keeping me
on track not so much for the day-to-day
but more for the trends and just
understanding the types of behaviors and
habits that influence things like HRV
and the amount of Ram or deep sleep that
I'm getting every night and how that
impacts resting heart rate stress like
all those sort of things like just it's
just
information that arms you with the data
points to kind of solve the arithmetic
of what works for you and what's leading
you astray yeah I I love the Sleep data
and you know I agree I've I've been able
to identify a few different kind kind of
patterns I've noticed if I'm if I'm
working really late then my restorative
deep sleep is much lower mhm probably
going to bed thinking about all things
and then if you correlated that with
what your where your stress levels are
and how long it takes them to go down as
you go to sleep um because if you
haven't reduced those before going to
bed you're going to have a less restful
evening of of sleep yeah my recovery
today was 86% that's pretty good happy
with that yeah right on um all right
what else do we need to know uh I think
we have a good idea of in a general
sense of the type of interventions and
protocols that are going to be served up
as a result of this Challenge and then
of course at the tail end of this you're
going to retest all of this stuff but
what else do you want to
share um generally
about the challenge itself I mean
there's so much in here we have an
emphasis on fermented
foods based on evidence out of Justin
sonnenberg's lab and Chris Gardner's
work we have have information uh and
recommendations on both moderate and
high-intensity cardiovascular training
both of those are important they're
different stimuli um you know I see
exercis is very much like a a poly pill
poly pill some people might be familiar
with that um you can package up you know
like a a lipid lowering drug and a blood
pressure lowering drug and a blood
glucose lowering drug all into one thing
and and and take that as a
pharmaceutical drug exercise is similar
in that you have all of these different
types of exercise moderate intensity
cardio high intensity resistance
training and they are providing
different stimuli really important
stimuli to get different systems in the
body to adapt so we have a guide in
there for resistance training for that
moderate intensity cardiovascular
training for high-intensity interval
training again we start off gentle and
we progress it over the 12 weeks and
then there are as I mentioned before
there are uh some lifestyle habits and
things that we're wanting people to do
that we think will shift the the needle
and emotional health and so I'll give
one example of this um Tom gilovich is a
psychologist who did some fascinating
research looking
at regret at the end of someone
life what is it that accounts for the
most
regret and he was looking
at is it actions that they've taken
throughout their life or is it in
action his results were really really
insightful and a little bit
surprising so
76% of the regret
was through
inaction it was through things that
people wish they did that they didn't
Doh now importantly he was able to
identify through different questions you
know each of us have kind of he
describes this as our actual self that's
who we are today who we think we are and
then we have our a self our allart self
is who we ought ought to be from society
expectation
what Society kind of wants us to to be
or um conform to and then we have our
ideal self and our ideal self is who we
truly want to grow
into the
76% of the
regret was explained 76% of the time by
in action towards the ideal self mhm so
it was and they had they have all of
these quotes from people it was simple
things Rich it was people who wanted to
pick up that musical instrument but
never did they wanted to write poetry
but never did they wanted to grow a
garden at home for their family but
never did and digging a little bit
deeper they were able to see
that the main reason reason why people
didn't take these actions Was
Fear a lot of the time it was fear of
what people around them would would
think or that they weren't going the
pressure to conform to the a self moving
the actual self towards the a rather
than the ideal self and the Delta
between the actual self and the ideal
self or the aspirational self is a
direct correlate to the extent to which
someone experiences regret on their
deathbed right and we get caught up in
that fear and those social expectations
we internalize them and and then we move
further and further away from the things
that authentically you know bring us
happiness yeah like I do this myself I
used to play the guitar when I was 15 16
and you know from when I was 10 up to
156 and then I remember getting to an
age where I started to to focus on you
know whether I was good enough and what
other people thought of me was you know
playing playing music and it no longer
was fun and I gave it up and I think you
know for the last five or 10 years I've
said to myself gosh should be good to
pick that guitar back up but I haven't
and if I'm being completely honest a lot
of that is fear of am I going to be good
enough is this going to be
embarrassing
and the interesting thing is that we're
all doing that so I'm sitting here
thinking about what everyone else is
going to be thinking of me and so I'm
not doing something and that's what
everyone else is doing and sure but the
good news Simon is that there's a 12we
program that's going to correct this for
you exactly so so my my challenge is I'm
going to have to come back on here and
play the guitar at some stage and make a
fool of myself but have fun that's good
well there there we go that that's
enough to you know appetite right well
we are going to do that um we're going
to do some followup checkin podcast
you're going to do a whole bunch of like
IG lives after February 1 um I'm going
to be in Australia on my sabatical
during um the first two weeks of of
February so maybe you and I can get
together and share some stuff or or see
where we're at while we're in the midst
of all of this should we go for a s in
barn oh that yeah that will be the
that's the embarrassing thing for me did
Ben Gordon tell you about me did I tell
you that story and I just oh God anyway
I'm not going to indulge people with
that but I actually am committed to
getting better at surfing that's a big
intention for me when I go back to
Australia and that requires just
consistently doing it like it's not that
I don't know how to do it it's that I
never do it you know and I enjoy it when
I have some level of fluidity with it
but I never invest the time to do it so
that's one of my that's like one of my
big things for that period of time which
happens to segue you know completely
overlap with this challenge period yeah
Ben's the guy to to help you do that
yeah I know I know he's uh he he he he's
like uh I got to make amends for the
last any whatever well he did take you
to he took me out and I was like listen
like I'm a super like I'm not a great
Surfer like let's just go where there's
nobody there and he's like sure and we
went to this break and the the break was
flat so he's like no don't worry we'll
go to the main Beach we'll just stay on
the outside or whatever sure enough
there's a million people out there and
I'm all up in my head about not getting
in anyone's way so of course I manifest
that very experience and I drop in on a
wave and I I accidentally there's a guy
in my blind spot and I you know without
meaning to kind of cut them off and our
boards Collide I go under and then the
fin just like slices my hand wide open
you know like and it was literally like
it was exactly what I told Ben I was
trying to avoid that I created yeah for
myself yeah took to the past so if
anyone is familiar with that that's
that's a crazy I love you and we'll be
going surfing soon but anyway I think
this is a good place to kind of bring
this to a conclusion but I do have a
couple quick questions first of which is
what is the role of supplements in all
of this when we have a conversation
around longevity and health span that
conversation tends to uh get sort of
hijacked by all of these new molec ules
that are being studied NAD you know
nmn NAD like all that kind of stuff
right rap ay what's going on there this
challenge is designed to look at the
biggest levers with the most heft and
while there's interesting science going
on at the pointy edge of longevity
what's most important are you know these
big levers right so with that kind of um
preface like do supplements fit into
this how does that work when somebody
gets their blood work done and they
realize maybe they have a deficiency
here and there does this account for
that my Approach with with supplements
is I look at it from two angles one is I
think supplementing with a particular
essential nutrient to fill a gap is
always a good idea if you can't adjust
your diet in a way to account for that
and the second is to take
a a supplement that can help optimize
you for particular performance goals
outcomes we've spoken about that
previously when we I think in the first
or second episode we did together where
we spoke a lot about creatin and and
protein and to your point about nmn and
rapy and Metformin some of these are
supplements some of these are
Pharmaceuticals I think that space is
super interesting but I think it's
speculative whereas the challenge is not
speculative in the sense that we do know
what markers matter in terms of
predicing our health and we do have
science-based interventions that we know
improve them so this whole challenge was
built upon that framework less
speculation more concrete science maybe
not as exciting to some corners of the
internet from a supplement point of
view with in the PDF there's a
supplement protocol
recommendation and some of these depend
on the way that someone's eating for
example I recommend a DHA EPA algae fish
oil depending on on someone's
preference if they're not consuming
fatty
fish and and actually rich I went and
looked at how much fatty fish you would
need to consume to get enough DHA and
EPA and terms of what's optimal and I
had a whole episode with Philip CER on
this who's the expert or one of the
domain specific experts researching
Omega-3s and six
is to get one gram of DHA and EPA a day
which is not a crazy high amount is what
I recommend because I think that's where
the evidence is lined with you would
need to be having three to four servings
of fatty fish a week m a very very small
percentage of the population would be
doing that and if everyone was doing
that quite frankly it would not be
sustainable so in short there are
recommendations for supplements like
that it's not going to apply to everyone
it will depend on their diet
Omega-3s a
multivitamin there's a Prebiotic
supplement which I think can be a good
idea if someone is increasing plant
diversity and having difficulty with
that is coming from a diet that's been
restricted creatin and protein mhm so
it's not a crazy long laundry list of of
supplements um it's just a handful or so
for people to consider and for each of
those there's a recommended brand
there's a recommended dosage and then
some links for people to get some
savings right what if somebody's blood
work comes back and it's way out of
range like they realize like those women
who realize they were osteopor erotic
that they're in a dire
state is there some you know kind of
guidance around when it might be
appropriate to you know call your doctor
and explore the options that are
available to you if somebody realizes
they're like really in the r or in a
crisis State on an important blood
marker yeah I think this is a great
point I think if anything is wildly out
of range then you should be having
discussion with your
physician it might be that some people
require pharmaceutical
interventions I also want people to sit
down with their physician if they have
type 2 diabetes if they have
cardiovascular disease if they have
metabolic syndrome and they're currently
taking medications and the reason for
that is that these interventions are
very effective and you want your
physician or primary care provider to
know that you're changing the way that
you're living because that could affect
the dose of various pharmaceutical
compounds that you have and they may
need to be titrated along the way so
another um I guess indicator of success
of this challenge is not just shifting
these into an optimal range but I would
see for many people is reducing the
dosage of some of the medications that
they're taking yeah if somebody's on
blood pressure medication they're on
statins they're on a battery of whatever
um you know obviously that complicates
uh you know the protocols I would
imagine in some regard like how does all
that play into
somebody's um you know day-to-day
program I think most of of you know if
not all of the 12 lifestyle habits you
know someone with type 2 diabetes could
do but I want their physician to be
aware that they're doing it mhm and the
primary concern that I have there is not
whether they can do these things it's
how it's going to affect their
physiology and therefore how that will
affect the medications that they're
likely taking MH so when you did this
retreat with Drew you sort of proofed
this or tested out some of this but it
wasn't a 12we retreat so I would imagine
you had some kind of compressed reduced
version of this
going through so you kind of initiated
it there and you stayed in touch with
those people yeah and we were you know I
guess one of the benefits of of a
retreat versus The Challenge is you you
can work on an individual basis a little
bit more with regards to the specific
interventions that they should focus on
based on those those 10 truths gives you
a little bit more flexibility there but
otherwise we took them through you know
essentially this same kind of protocol
and that was only in October so people
are sort of six or eight weeks into that
process now um I've had a lot of emails
from you know from our our guests who
have already done you know blood tests
they they couldn't wait 12 weeks they
had to go and this is the thing that it
doesn't take 12 weeks to to change all
of these biomarkers they some of these
change on different sort of time courses
like bone mineral density takes a lot
longer than a b you can reduce your a b
in many
instances um within you know a week of
changing your diet in the long run what
we're hoping to do and I see this very
much as kind of version 1.0 you know
each year we I want to be reviewing the
calculator the 10 truths looking at new
evidence that's emerging do we need to
tweak things in there in terms of how
we're scoring
it and then over time accumulating data
from people that are going through the
challenge so we can see the typical
outcomes MH and then you know that way
you can you know before someone decides
to sign up to this and and commit to 12
weeks they can kind of understand what
benefits are are up for grabs mhm I'm
trying to uh put myself in the shoes of
the contrarian who's watching this or
listening to this and thinking do I
really need to do all this cuz when I
look at the blue zones folks and what
Dan Butner has to say these people lived
100 and Beyond they're all fit and
seemingly doing great and they don't
worry about any of this they're not
counting their calories they're not
doing beep tests or Shuttle tests
they're not checking their email they're
not worried about how many plants
they're eating every day they're living
their life lives and uh they're they're
rocking it out so can I just get like
blue zones adjacent and call it a day
Simon I think you can if you're prepared
to move to
okanawa or perhaps a certain part of
Costa Rica but short of changing your
environment to their
environment unfortunately I think we
have to be intentional the environment
that we live in is very different to
their environment
and I think I've heard Dan puer argue
this before it's not willpower that
separates us you know centenarians in
blue zones don't aren't born with you
know crazy amounts of
willpower they just live in an
environment environment are conducive to
those choices yeah and I think the best
way to kind of visualize this is to
think of the difference between a maze
and a labyrinth
mhm you know a a labyrinth
is kind of designed for you to find your
way you don't have to make choices along
the way there's only one path and
eventually you'll get to the middle in
fact some of these labyrinths are
designed to be you know useful for the
purpose of mindfulness or meditation
that's the the point of them whereas a
maze is really designed for you to get
get lost and so a blue zone is more like
a
labyrinth the environment is set up for
them to succeed they don't have to be
intentional they can just walk through
that environment and they're going to be
very likely to enjoy good health and get
to the center of that Labyrinth find
their way out of it whereas in Western
countries where we're exposed to a
different food environment food
marketing is different we have a
different way of living that results in
a more sedentary
lifestyle it's more like a maze designed
for us to get lost
so the
challenge and you know the information
that I put out on my show and all the
information that you put out on your
show with with guests with a health and
and wellness sort of
background I see those as you know
acting as a a voice so that as people
are walking through the maze you get to
a point where you have to go left or
right yeah don't go that way go so just
a little whisper you know and and so you
know with that coming back to where we
started this conversation in that maze
giving people more confidence empowering
them so that they you know they
feel confident that the the energy and
the time that they're putting into
certain things is going to pay off there
is going to be a return on investment
and I think we're super lucky I'm
incredibly grateful for all of this
science that we have that allows us it
informs this so we can come at this in
an environment that let's face it it is
designed for us to fail we live in a
maze but we do have
information that allows us to be
intentional so that we can still enjoy
good health despite the environment well
I think it's a laudible thing that
you've created and I think that what's
great about it is that amidst the
acrimonious discourse that you find
online and on social media around diet
tribalism most of those arguments take
place on the margins of what we know and
don't yet know and Overlook the pillars
upon which we agree upon and truly
understand to be most potent and
important in terms of you know as we
said at the outset of this moving the
needle on the biggest things that impact
our health and our well-being so we can
argue about you know I don't know you
name it seed oils whatever but we know
that most people die of heart attacks
heart disease right and what are the
interventions that we fully understand
are going to put us in a position to
avoid those pitfalls and focusing on
that seems to be you know the
responsible choice here and then down
the line through the various um you know
10 truths that we talked about uh I love
it I like that it is
allinclusive and that it isn't
contingent upon your affiliation with
any particular dietary tribe per se and
uh it's easy to understand easy to adopt
and it is like placing a labyrinth on
top of this maze to create a structure
and a foundation and an environment
where somebody is Whispering so you
don't make that wrong left turn and and
you can kind of get on board with these
habits which are not you're not asking
that much it's not a super heavy lift
it's very gentle and I think it provides
people with a warm introduction and
welcome into a new way of being in
relationship with themselves and their
daily habits so I commend you I'm
excited to do it well thank you for I
mean you played a big role in pushing me
I guess to kind of pull all this
together and you know I want to
reiterate I'm just a synthesizer of this
information the I've been so grateful
for all of the guests that I've had the
the privilege of being able to sit down
with how many episodes have you done
it's coming up to 300 I've been doing
this for six years now I started
actually in Venice that Airbnb where you
came over the other night that's that's
where this started oh that was the
original OG Airbnb wow full circle uh
but I'm so grateful for not only the
conversations that I've had but the
relationships that I've been able to
build with different academic scientists
domain specific experts that's allowed
me to have ongoing emails and phone
calls and to really lean on on people um
to help decipher all of this and and
make sense of it and then be able to
translate and communicate it um to to my
community and other communities to me um
you know I'm just very grateful for that
and obviously to to people like Drew
Harrisburg that have played a huge role
in in sort of building out this
challenge as well yeah well I think it's
the evolution of this medium like you
had so many conversations but they're
long and it's a lot and if you're
somebody who's new to this world you
can't ask somebody to go listen to 300
episodes of your podcast how do you
synthesize that information deliver it
in a package that's organized around a
protocol or a series of protocols a
program if you will uh that's doable and
that's what you've done you know and I
think
um they've done a great job I mean this
is like not an easy task you know
especially when you can get caught up in
the weeds you know and go down these
rabbit holes like it's just an endless
you know black hole or whatever cuz it's
hard like nutrition science man it gets
super complicated we want to be
reductionist about it and make it binary
or black or white and it's not quite
that way and for somebody who
appreciates and understands like the
complexity and the level of nuance to be
able to still nonetheless plant your
flag here here here here's what's
important
I'm sure that was uous for you that was
hard but I I I've had to lean on a
number of you know soundboards I guess
in my life people that can give me
honest feedback to pull me out of the
weeds and say yeah simplify that that
doesn't make sense uh but as you you
know as you say you can't Point people
to 300 episodes so you I
feel uh I guess proud is the word that
comes to mind that now
when someone says and this happens all
the time just tell me what to do yeah I
can just say well go to the proof.com
finally you have an answer yeah and
start there there it is so we are going
to kick this thing off February 1 that
gives you a full month to get your blood
work done and do all the testing to
create your Baseline in the meantime
everybody needs to go to the proof.com
livingproof you'll be be able to
download the PDF enter your email get on
the email list again this is all zero
cost no cost to you obviously you have
to pay for your blood work or whatever
that's on you but the program itself is
free which you know that's another
fantastic aspect of this and Simon is
going be once February first starts
Simon's gonna be doing IG livees you're
going to be sharing a lot of stuff
making videos I'm going to be in
Australia for part of it so maybe we'll
do a check-in podcast something like
that or do create some content around
this and uh I'm excited man thanks
thanks for pushing me to do this after
our last 3-hour date time yeah maybe
we'll we'll figure out what to do W with
that but you're going to be spending
more time in LA next year right I am I
think I'm doing five or six months from
February all right so plenty of time for
you to pop in like I think if we even
just looked at that and did separate
episodes on all of those things we could
create something a little bit more
concrete and helpful to people so more
to come thanks Rich excellent brother uh
check out Simon's podcast of course as
well the proof and uh I have this book
sitting right here the proof is in the
plants all kinds of recipes science
nutrition info all the good stuff and uh
love you buddy thank you for sharing and
uh to be continued love you man thanks
peace
proof that's it for today thank you for
listen listening I truly hope you
enjoyed the conversation to learn more
about today's guest including links and
resources related to everything
discussed today visit the episode page
at Rich roll.com where you can find the
entire podcast archive as well as
podcast merch my books Finding Ultra
voicing change and the plant power way
as well as the plant power meal planner
at meals. ral.com if you'd like to
support the podcast the easiest and most
impactful thing you can do is to
subscribe to the show on Apple podcasts
on Spotify and on YouTube and leave a
review and or comment supporting the
sponsors who support the show is also
important and appreciated and sharing
the show or your favorite episode with
friends or on social media is of course
awesome and very helpful and finally for
podcast updates special offers on books
the meal planner and other subjects
please subscribe to our newsletter which
you can find on the footer of any page
at Rich roll.com Today's show was
produced in engineered by Jason Cameo
with additional audio engineering by
Kale Curtis the video edition of the
podcast was created by Blake ctis with
assistance by our creative director Dan
Drake portraits by Dave Greenberg
graphic and social media assets courtesy
of Daniel CIS thank you Georgia Wy for
copywriting and website management and
of course our theme music was created by
Tyler Patt Trapper Patt and Harry mathys
appreciate the love love the support see
you back here soon peace plance
[Music]
namaste